meet a doctor now scientists out of Hong
Kong who says she was doing research on
covin 19 in December in January that
could have saved lives but she says her
supervisor swept it under the rug doctor
Li mignon says she escaped to the United
States and tell her stories he joins me
live now for her first TV interview in
this exclusive chat today and welcome
doctor here you arrived in the u.s. at
the end of April you say you're now in
hiding you believe the Chinese communist
government has lied about what yeah
exactly exactly TMI and I have to hide
because I know how they treated we saw
Hoover and as a result over here I won't
tell the truth of cuvee 90 and origins
of the South korea-us ask away to two
people to the word so I have to keep
safety okay dr. what did the Chinese lie
about that you can prove okay first I
mentioned in the video in folks our
government already know that before the
end of December there are over 40 people
get in fact it's not as I mentioned like
27 and also most importantly there are
human to human transmission already at
that time but they keep mining until
middle of June actually 20 June they are
the mid heat okay so your claim is that
at the end of December there was human
to human transition and the Chinese
government and the World Health
Organization did not cop to that until
about three weeks later if you're right
how would things be different around the
world and here in the US okay let me
explain to you first this is a huge
panda me we have seen in the world it's
more than everything we know in human
history so but at the timing is very
very important so if we can stop it we
can see a lot of life that's the Cape
hunt okay so you you have said then I
invited your husband to come with you he
did not you have spoken with the FBI who
is investigating your story doctor FBI
have that and also many other people
from US government they have done that I
contacted me they need to verify my
story ok can you prove it doctor for
example I have the receipt that FBI
agent lay for me that they have hold my
Sloane cell phone from Los Angeles
Airport and then return it back to meet
several days later in New York yes sir
just to be clear not can you prove
whether or not you talk to the FBI can
you prove your claim
I can show you oh yeah I have a lot of
evidence like how I communicate with the
people in China CDC and also because of
my network I have a lot of friends to
working in the first man in the third
zone of China during : 19
I have talking a this kind of chat
record to them and also I can show it to
you later ok so you you believe your
life is in jeopardy and you will not go
back to Hong Kong how come of course
because I know how to treat
whistleblowers for the case that's how
our government has done to keep people
silent and if they won't reveal the
truth not only about Kobe 19 but also
for the other things happen in China for
example during such time the senior
doctor professor Jung had revealed it in
Beijing Anton he got punished and also
this time professor Chang Cheh in
Shanghai his team revealed the sequence
of the SAS Kobe - at the first time in
the world and published 8 our nature on
3rd February this year and then his pee
stream are both shut down by the comment
well but the Chinese embassy here in the
US is they don't know who you are and to
quote them they say we've never heard of
this person referring to you what do you
say to that doctor of course they won't
know me because I'm not top biologist
they know who worked directly as a
consultant for tablet issue but I am the
one who worked with them directly and I
am the core team member in that part
in that lab who communicate K today's
China's first month doctors to taste a
blue hmm okay last question here and I
asked you who's investigating your story
maybe I can reframe the question what is
the US government now able to do with
your information doctor if you're right
I'm willing to tell all the things I
know provide all the evidence to US
government and I want them to understand
I also want us people to understand how
terrible this is is not what you have
thought it's not what you have read
through the medium amazing from our
China government even WH oh this is
something really different and we have
to chase true trista true evidence and
get a real answer because this is a key
part to solve this pandemic
if not we really don't have much time
well if you're right doctor you are
showing an awful lot of courage in your
own personal life today
you can reveal about your story at
foxnews.com doctor thank you for your
timely mingyang here in the United
States good luck to you I hope you stay
thank you very much thank you doctor